you know I know we all know when it
confuses us when we feel strange and sad
because of it when we try to ignore it
and pretend like we don't know you still
know I still know we all still know when
it's truth scares us when it's truth
scares our friends when it's truth
scares our family when no one ever
really talks about it
you still know I still know we all still
know when people talk like they know
when people live like they know we say
don't do that not here not now be better
be stronger don't show it but you still
know I still know we all still know a
morning jog a house chore a hobby a job
a friend a lover a drink a pill you
still know I still know we all still
know when we can't get away from it when
we are confused about how we have done
everything right but it's not enough
when the whole world hates that it
exists so it acts like it doesn't we
might wonder right now what do I know
what does he know what do we all know
what is this about but you know I know
we all know
you